prep the veg chop spring onions shallots  a clove of garlic and chili to taste  then thinly slice celery add a bay leaf  and Thyme veg ready  add oil to a pan and Fry  [Music]  season then add mussels and stir  muscles were my favorite shellfish cheap  healthy and delicious cover and steam  for a couple of minutes  as the mussels open add vermouth and  aromatic 45 wine  and 150 ml of dry white wine  on a high heat reduce the liquid to  create a source  discard any mussels that are still shut  and finish with Creme Fraiche and  chopped parsley  minimal prep and cooked in less than 10  minutes my muscles were celery and  chilly impressive affordable and super  speedy